no I'm going to spend this afternoon in
the water though it's absolutely
gorgeous here today in Plymouth the Sun
is out and everybody's out on the ho
it's a magnificent day here
you must be exceptionally delighted
because you're a Plymouth boy yes I grew
up here in this city I mean just to give
this announcement a little bit of
context 150 years ago the great big
national parks on lands began to be
built but what we did is we did we
forgot about the oceans and how
important it was to protect the oceans
and this announcement today is historic
it's pioneering for me it's an absolute
delight to see this happening here in
the city which I grew up as a young boy
what is the phrase National Marine Park
actually mean so what it means so what
has been happening now is that we
realize that there's so many
organizations and different people using
the waters here in Plymouth Sound
because the Royal Navy we've got the
fishing community we've got the shipping
community we got conservationists
scientists and swimmers and everybody is
using this area and it's also home to as
you mentioned earlier on over a thousand
different species of wildlife and and in
order to be able to create this marine
protected area it's important that every
single one of these groups is involved
in protecting it because what we found
in other parts of the world is that
unless everybody is involved then the
possibility of these things working is
reduced for people that don't know the
area just described Plymouth Sound to us
well Plymouth science obviously in the
southwest here of the United Kingdom
it's a it's a fairly large area we've
got two rivers coming down and it is
home obviously to a large part of the
Royal Navy it truly is one of the most
magnificent parts of the south coast of
England a Plymouth describes itself as
Britain's ocean city and it certainly is
that now how significant is this marine
park given that as you mentioned they're
talking about the Royal Navy it's home
to the largest naval base in Western
Europe
I think it's very very significant it's
not just significance for this city it's
not just significant for the United
Kingdom but I hope that it's significant
also for other countries and the reason
is because this is a process we're
learning how to start building these
national marine parks the lessons which
we learn here in Plymouth we hope to
share with all the other towns and
cities around the United Kingdom and
also with the rest of the world what
lessons have you learned then or have
been learned there
well the main lesson is just how
important it is every single stakeholder
has a voice in creating these marine
protected areas where we've created
marine protected areas in other parts of
the world and local communities don't
have a voice they really don't work but
when everybody has a voice when
everybody feels ownership of these
protected areas then they really do work
and paint the picture for us I mean
people will think that this area of
water is just full of muds but I mean a
thousand different species what water
down there no no no it's far from mud
this is one of the most vibrant pieces
of our coastline in the United Kingdom
when I swam along the the coastline here
this was absolutely magnificent I swam
past the lighthouse a few kilometres out
to sea underneath me is kelp there's
fish there's dolphins there's a thousand
different marine species underneath us
just because we can't see them and just
because the water isn't this turquoise
blue which you see in them you know in
other parts of world doesn't mean that
it isn't a vibrant ecosystem